we have the hot ones movie poster from
the interview with key & peele it's
autographed by each of those so [ __ ]
[ __ ] is everything that we love about
the show internally but like never [ __ ]
let me try over flu game right people
don't know people don't know Dom rain
sleet or snow hot ones hey what's going
on spice Lords this is Sean Evans
checking in with a sinus infection from
the hot ones Museum of curiosities in
the coming weeks we'll have
announcements about the launch of season
six including our new hot sauce lineup
reveal but first things first as you
know it's tradition around here at the
end of a season to put my ass in the hot
seat and answer some of your
hard-hitting hot ones fan questions but
first things first a tour of the museum
we have our movie poster from our junket
style interview with key and Peele one
of the 10th Paul haplin's episodes my
day ones know what I'm talking about to
the left of me a star talk tie signed by
Neil deGrasse Tyson we also have a rich
Brian fanny pack
they call it a fanny pack because it
gets you a lot of Fannie's
save some [ __ ] for the rest of us
amigos we have the Polaroids that we've
taken with our guests over the years
cookbooks Tyra's book and then one of my
favorites dat ranch
it's the ranch that vince staples
brought to the hot one set you'd think
that we'd have thrown it out months ago
but no here it is forever enshrined in
hot ones lore
[Music]
a ukulele signed by let's touch gooks
John Mayer himself - Sean - much much
the logic Rubik's Cube one of her
all-time great winged tens he was kind
enough to sign it for us the hot ones
Museum of curiosities it might not be
the Guggenheim it might not be the Met
but damn if it is not to me but just
being around this I have to be real with
you
it is emotional it does make me think
about the five plus seasons that we
spent together the hundred plus episodes
that we've been on this journey because
the fans the spice Lords the spicy boys
the spicy girls hot ones nation it's
what fuels this whole thing so without
further [ __ ] around
Sean burger hit me with the list of
questions whenever you're ready you did
this first one is from Alec rye Sean
what was your favorite moment from
season five when I think back on season
five two episodes that really stand out
to me number one the Charlize Theron
episode because she's so high-profile
such a superstar and on paper this show
is still so stupid so you never really
know how someone's going to take to it
that's it's really special to us and our
crew is when it performs better than we
expect it better than we drew it up that
is the best thing possible that's the
hurdle that we're always trying to jump
the other one is the Tyra Banks episode
because she walks in and she's so
charismatic and larger-than-life
she has our crew laughing she's eating
ice cream she's tapping in her mom she's
dying camera guy bill who by the way
he's on the main right now you put your
best guy on the wide and there he is in
his striped shirt always dressed to
impress but those are some that stand
out to me and then others off the top of
my head Shawn Mendes John Mayer Michael
B Jordan and then Trick Daddy shout out
to eat a bootie gang this next one is
from XCore which celebrity can you most
relate to and why I think I can relate
to the guests that have shows where
their talk-show hosts and interviewers
off the top of my head people like Adam
Richman
people like Eddie Wong people like
Charlamagne tha God Rachael Ray they
kind of understand what it's like to
play point guard on a production they
understand what it's like to go through
a run a show to write out interview
questions to try to create that
chemistry that fire right there on the
spot those are the people that I find
myself really talking shop with so I
would say those people this next one is
from champs creed
do you eat ass believe it or not my 32
years on this earth I have never eaten
but that said my interest is piqued
during my conversation with Trick Daddy
I am NOT a prude and I'm open to trying
anything so if ever the moment arose or
the opportunity was there and it felt
right I'm not against it you know I'm
not closing that window and painting it
shut if that's where it goes that's
where it goes if it continues to go
there continues to go there if it stops
after one time it stops after one time
but we will climb that mountain when it
is time to climb that mountain and I'll
tell you all exactly how it went all
right next question I think it's safe to
say that taraji B Henson was on the most
controversial interviews this season if
not in all of hot ones history what do
you think of the interview you know I
think that sometimes I'm in a position
where I'm protecting guests from
over-critical fans I think that there's
always such an extreme reaction whether
it's dj khaled or taraji or whoever
where I'm like Jesus like it's just a
YouTube show chill out a little bit but
at the same time you know with the
taraji episode I would say that when we
walked out of the room yeah it was a
little bit jarring that somebody walked
in and didn't really play to the format
it didn't go exactly how we drew it up
but then it was an important reminder
for us internally that like out of that
was berthed bodyguard Dave and so when
you look at episodes that have a unique
viewer experience that are divisive I
think that that's a reminder that
sometimes the unpredictable is good like
yeah you can have somebody like t-pain
who loves hot ones comes onto the show
knows exactly what to expect and it has
that certain feel to it but at the same
time it's interesting to see how
somebody would react to it when they
have
don't [ __ ] clue what it is or what's
going on or what this whole thing is at
the end of a press day alright next hey
Sean longtime follower first-time caller
anyway why don't you just keep the
laptop next to you from the beginning
and why is it not already logged into
Instagram I'm happy to address the
laptop because it's probably the thing
that fans talk to me most about which is
berserk to me alright first off your
bike wow you get an iPad get an iPad why
you just get an iPad what problem does
that even solve like alright iPad please
now I'm just holding an iPad like an
idiot ok like what problem does that
solve the laptops just there what does
the iPad do does the iPad do anything
does that solve any problem other than
now I have to hold something so iPad
police out of my mentions please and
then the laptop the laptop is logged
into Instagram my laptop is password
protected so if you hear me I'm just
getting it into my laptop and then the
other side of it is this it's a nice
little refresh alright here we are
halfway through laptop please hey
Gabrielle Union how you doing you
hanging in there ok cool
do you need a new water do you need a
refresh on your milk you know at some
point I have to do some things for
myself and not get bossed around by the
comments section so the laptop is here
to stay I'm not backing down from it you
heard it here first on the season 5 rap
fan QA from the Museum of curiosities
from my cold dead hands
next Robert Nelson asks are y'all
purposely holding all the last dab to
create a supply and demand situation
just weird that I can find though ebay
for $100 a bottle but the heat in this
store says sold out for $20 alright
here's the situation we can't keep up
with the demand
because pepper X grows on one farm and
the demand for said pepper out reaches
that farm we try as fast as we can grow
it as fast as we can bottle it we sell
it this is from Noah at Heat nest do not
spend $100 on eBay
buying a bottle of last death there's
always another harvest we have other
versions we have the Scorpion pepper we
have the Carolina Reaper
hopefully we even grow it out from there
there's always gonna be another
opportunity to buy a bottle of the last
dab at retail you just have to find when
that opportunity is going to be maybe
subscribe to a mailing list maybe set up
some sort of alert if you're that
interested in getting the bottle of hot
sauce but do not spend a hundred dollars
on eBay we do not want to turn this into
the supreme line that is not our goal so
just find your moment find your
opportunity have your information ready
send that through and then get your
bottle of hot sauce but don't spend a
hundred dollars on eBay that's absurd
this next one is from Michael did you
become a friend or keep in touch with
the guests if so how did it happen and
who is it I found myself really drawn to
the comedians I love going to the comedy
store and seeing a lot of the comic
guests that we've had on the show and
yeah there are some benefits to it you
know when post Malone's coming to town
just shoot him a DM hey dude can you
make me look cool in front of a girl and
then before you know it I'm just up in
the balcony VIP popping bottles and
singing the words to too young so yeah
it has its benefits the perks are
amazing but what we're most proud of is
that you know people come in here they
have such a great experience
maybe they thank me like it was some
sort of free therapy session but then
they do want to still be involved and
support us and stay in touch and that to
us is the most special thing this next
one is from Tim stalker
is hot ones grows in popularity are you
ever concerned that a guess might be too
niche for a wider audience so you're
never gonna make everyone happy with a
celebrity interview show there are some
people that just watch YouTube there's
some people that go to blockbusters
there are times when maybe we'll have
Ricky Gervais soar Hannibal Buress on an
episode and in the comments we'll just
see like who is this nobody get prank
guy game guy Jeff he's huge on Twitch
and just be like what we're really proud
that we've had a listers on the show but
that's not why we do the show you know
we've never really wanted to be like
Late Night with chicken wings and no
matter how big hot ones gets we'll
always want to be eclectic you know the
reason that we created this show is
because celebrity interview shows are
boring so how do you make it not boring
we bring in hot sauce but it's
not just that it's that somebody
interview shows always interview the
same types of gas with the same types of
people with the same kinds of anecdotes
so we've wanted to widen the net on
everything and if you're still mad it's
a fair transaction with the audience you
have their picture you have their name
in the description if you don't want to
watch it you don't have to watch it
there's prank guy game guy Jeff on
Twitch and he's live-streaming fortnight
and it's awesome you can just go check
that out instead it's a it's a big open
world of content nothing can stop you
there's no need to click for things just
so that you can get mad at Shawn Mendes
it just doesn't doesn't make any sense
alright one more
when is the show's creator gonna be on
the show does he not have the courage to
face his own monster shout-out to Chris
Shawn burger he and I spend a lot of
time together and I think that he'd be
the first to admit that he would maybe
not be the greatest guest on the show
not exactly up to YouTube's snuff if you
know what I'm saying
but we always joke about it and it's
true Chris will be the last guest that
we ever have on the show so more in the
day because if you ever see Chris's
goofball face on a thumbnail for hot
ones it means that the show is over it's
the last one that we ever do all right
well there you have it it's another post
season Q&A in the books now there's
nothing left to do but hit yeah with the
one shining moment montage from the
season that was season 5 catch you later
season 6 nice to meet you coming into
port many exciting announcements on the
way but before we kick off our montage I
just want to say thank you to the hot
ones fans who've rocked with us through
season one through season two through
season three through season four through
season five and into season six roll the
tape hey what's going on everybody four
first we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings I've
been so curious about like how hot these
wings actually are this will be the
ultimate test the ones with like the
explosives are where I'm
worried I'm very very very scary I'm
gonna tap out I'm telling you no
surprise here ain't no thing but a
chicken wing oh yeah it's hot
yep it is hot yes it is yeah yeah yeah
by the way I have a lot of experience
with being highly uncomfortable in these
situations for like first dates just
feels like I'm catching up with an old
friend my ability to connect with you
right now I've been here before
that's why we want you all you into a
false sense of security
oh my goodness I just love that you're
encouraging me through the hot sauce
challenge it's a little bit interview
it's a little bit life coach over here
is it true that you started class by
having all the students take one-minute
videos of themselves yes how do you know
that don't worry yeah you did your
research huh you're a great interviewer
and I like I like seeing people in pain
eating ass has really picked up steam
over the last couple years do you still
get down like that or is it lost a
little bit of its charm now that
everyone's jumping on the bandwagon
there's but this much wool the separate
from the hay
all right so this is number one busy
guitar okay who's eating this for me
where's my stunt double mic on bill with
that wing in your mouth bill Hajis
security detail
taking out wings I just want to flip
that bottle off like you just ruined
this whole thing for me if I if I was
rating them one two I hate my tongue
right now I feel like I'm gonna throw up
on this table live the tradition
what the hell does that mean what are
you doing
this is the last dab Oh am i dramatic
right now we call it the last dab
because it's tradition around here to
put a little extra last wing did you
make this up so has the sauce already
with an extra you don't have to holy
[ __ ]
if you don't want to I mean you did it I
got kind of like how can I add a feeling
that's what it's almost gonna do you
take a bite of that that would be the
point behind everything you do and say
is this little quiet implication don't
be a [ __ ]
cheers my man cheers all right Cheers
sure see you on the other side see on
the other side
[Music]
doubling comes in late and hard mofo
super [ __ ] hard
that is real bro it's real it's real
I've never seen me like this before
oh there's a hopper that I thought or
whatever it to like I would I'm the best
you are the best app out there will be
some naysayers yes the [ __ ] we did it
in the what our run it's been getting
through the hot ones gauntlet I feel
almost guilty but at the same time not
pissed at all is about to hear from me
[Music]
you